you know it's interesting there is a
study done recently that talks about how
actually it's at the college level that
a lot of women start to lose they're not
there necessarily their interest in
leadership but start to not see
themselves as leaders so I think one of
the things we need to do and we do some
of this already is I think at the high
school level really encourage young
women and encourage leadership encourage
them to take leadership roles and then I
think we have to make sure we follow
through with that at the college level
given that that's where we know that
that's something breaks down there I
think in addition to that a lot of women
I think you know politics has become so
nasty and so ugly I think a lot of women
are just too smart for that trick
whereas I think men like you know all
think they should be president and I say
that as someone who loves men I think
women you know find other ways to make
change the other thing though is a lot
of women are intimidated about asking
for money because it takes so much money
to run for office and so that's why
there are groups like Emily's list that
sort of help women and sort of train
them and some of the key elements of
what it means to run for office how to
put together a campaign how do how to
ask for money
so that it's kind of the lower that
barrier to entry for women
I believe we will have a woman president
in my lifetime which is exciting as a
woman of color to have both a woman na
african-american president like to have
lived through that that's pretty awesome
I think for women you're seeing more
women get into politics I mean I
remember when I first got out of college
I was living in California and Barbara
Boxer and Diane Feinstein they were the
California was the first state to be
represented by two women and now you
have so many more women both Republican
and Democrat in the Senate and one of
the things about the women and I think
one of the reasons why women's
leadership is so important remember that
it was the women of the Senate who broke
the logjam on the budget issues that we
were having last year part of that is
because part of women's leadership and
part of what the women in the Senate do
they get together on a regular basis
they have that personal and professional
relationship where they can call on each
other and you know to sort of help get
things done and so I think we'll see
more women get coming into office in
part because the more women see other
women doing it the more I think we start
to think okay I can do that too and also
I think we're starting to see the impact
of having women both at the corporate
level and you know the Senate and the
house that that impact that women have
just on the issues that we're talking
about or how we're talking about issues
me think about I thought about when John
Kerry was SEC became Secretary of State
I was like oh whoa we haven't had a man
in a while that's pretty cool so I think
the more we see women in those roles
again I think the more it encourages
more women to get into it
I think one of the big things that I
certainly hope happens is that we reach
a breaking point with regard to the
amount of money that is spent in
elections a because it does create such
a barrier to entry for I think a lot of
good people who would like to run for
office and who probably would be great
whether they're mayor or in Congress or
their Senate you know whatever the state
legislature but it's become so expensive
so I hope that you know all the outside
money I hope there's a breaking point
where the American people just say
enough is enough I mean we're talking
about in 2016 we're looking at billions
I mean one organization the Koch
brothers have said they're gonna spend a
billion dollars and the campaigns are
planning on raising you know
unprecedented levels of money so I'm
hoping that we reach a tipping point and
we kind of go back on citizens united
and say you know what we gotta rein this
back in because I think it would mean we
in the future we would have more
wonderful people wanting to get into
public service
I would say that as messed up as it
seems as hard as it seems it actually
does matter and one of my mentors talks
about politics as the art of making
things possible and all those sort of in
the big picture I think politics has
become very partisan and very polarized
there are still things getting done and
particularly at the state and local
level that's where you're really seeing
I think a lot of innovation in terms of
how to solve some of our problems that
we're having in terms of you know
whether it's income inequality raising
the minimum wage childcare so I would
say change is possible and do it in you
know even if you just do it in your
corner of the world that actually
matters if you don't it doesn't have to
be any sometimes people think I'm gonna
change the world that's great too if you
can do that but if you can bring change
again to your corner of the world that's
going to matter too
you